hi happy Friday we are streaming the
bunker a live-action FMV horde game I
haven't really played it only tested
like the first few minutes of it it's
pretty weird but let's get into it if
you have any questions put them the chat
had a fat Q right in front of it and I
will do my best to read them and answer
them here we go
it's gonna I I really don't know what
we're walking into let's just do it yeah
a little scared
hate offices
so this is on PC
kurayan playing on a PC
it's a keeper shakes hands
I could see that hate last push
good question
as a boy
Boulder
oh that's right it was Jessica light
here we go
breathe baby sick
the end
okay No
Oh
you've got to say it again John oh yeah
you forgot to say it again I thought was
mr. booty they'll be safe shooting an
audio delay all right
let's read mom a book domestic nuclear
shelters Treasure Island or the Bible
she loves this book
spit problem
we're in for a ride
I could feel it John
so in case you haven't noticed this is
this actors name is Adam Brown he was in
The Hobbit
he played Ori if you recall all right
the routine day 11 109 109 that any days
whatever alright because I click that
okay
mum said I have to keep my vitamin B
levels up
all right
we got in here some fitna means this I
need to take my vitamins first that's
right mom's up there
mama said take a villains
all right this is great Oh
radiation is just over 70 ml that's
acceptable now look at that
it's flying right through these radio
it's a good station
dang this is dark it's no one alive up
there so yeah obviously the nuclear
explosion killed a lot of people I guess
and you're all you know is the bunker
very much like a fallout game
11100 nine days in the bunker survivors
one so I guess mom and me were the last
people in the bunker geez
uncle radiation is normal good that is
good
check food
hmmm I need to choose dinner
Peach's my favorite so that makes 27
years three months and 14 days of food
what oh man
that's one way to eat food jeez peaches
on the toilet
my favorite mother how's she doing
hmm
that's what outside looks like
apparently
Oh
where her eyes something like that
I'm not very good at drawing
I like to do drawings
she liked it when I read to her
we had a dreary morning's work before us
there were no sign of any wind
you got achievement for reading books
and land and the ship wrapped three or
four miles around the corner of the
island and around the narrow passages to
the Haven behind skeleton island I
volunteered from one of the boats
wherever I had
all right
so yeah there is a point I have to stop
streaming due to embargo restrictions
all over again oh man this is the skies
life oh this is crazy I want to do that
radiation is nearly eight EMR is
increasing
man
ah 27 years 3 months and 13 days left
in one hole out the other it's pretty
good method
yeah we had a dreary morning's work
before us there were no sign of any wind
and the boats had gone out and land and
the ship wrapped three or four miles
around the corner of the island and
around the narrow passages to the Haven
behind skeleton island
I volunteered for one of the boats where
I had
double-kill right there I'm getting good
at chicken all right
11111 also known as one one one one one
oh man I know this part nailed it
radiation oh no my 80 and maha wait was
it a um yeah it was
I heard some muffling
I think that was good no the procedural
manual where is it I think wasn't I
reading it to mom I let's take a look at
these things I don't know what to do
man this guy's the scariest part of the
game my old diary today is my birthday
and I have had extra peaches my favorite
and there was a candle mom gave me his
book and depends look here are the
colors he assigned me a ring a ring of
roses she said she was crying because
she is happy it's my birthday and then
she and PJ and Louie and mum sang me
happy birthday but not too loud I blew
up the candle this book is going to be
my book about my friends today I will
start a new friend he would look like
this he will be a soldier because I have
a general but I need a bigger army I've
got a block from the map room but I had
to hide mr. Bishop was there
he nearly saw me he was shouting he says
I am a waste I think he's a waste I will
make the soldier and mr. Churchill and
Joan of Arc will tell him to fight mr.
Bishop
we had ham today it's a source of pink
and sticky it is better than sardines
which are the worst mum has made my
knife sharp infinitas doing my soldier
she says rocky was the best of winning
fight so that's his name I finished
Rocky so here all my friends
Commissioner didn't make it I guess
today is my birthday and I have had
extra peaches my favorite and there were
the candles mum ok ok I don't need new
underwear right now yeah you do my
underwear drawer I don't need new
underwear right now I like to wear no
underwear
my new yeah
okay make an announcement that may that
mean that mains power is being shut down
for Mainers on fuse box BAM in the
storage room
identify damaged fuses find the fuses
shut power off my rights when the sound
wait ten seconds
place fuse switch power back on perform
a systems check which would be back here
find the fuse box level to find the fuse
box level two
good call
Oh
mom
all right find the fuse box one upon two
right what's in here though
just my locker any of that
I'm not sure I can do this
all right security can't be who's
watching me
I can go this way all right now I am
into this
sickbay or the storage room maybe
there's a weapon here let's check I know
this room
nothing in here but beans beans make me
go poopoo all right let's go in here
sickbay this I'd be good I wonder if
this is where mom is
Oh
what all right what blood I wonder when
people died date fourth of July
96 patients named Vera Taylor patient
reports headache from Monday a.m.
vomiting and diarrhea Wednesday also
coughed with occasional blood
intermittent bow pain increasing pain in
chest temperature fluctuating peaks at a
hundred point five degrees blood present
in feces conclusions patients showing
signs of radiation sickness plan sick
based a white blood count test monitor
potassium iodide 130 milligrams orally
per day for four days review possible
dtpa course notes taken by evidence
all right I can't explain it radiation
sickness not blood good call
so I guess just I can't go backwards all
right let's keep go Oh
at door only opens in an emergency
the map lights up if there's a leak
Oh
I thought
this is where I came from
oh that's just where I have okay I got
an SS where I have the body
you see splendid
mama don't know
do it John
there must be a key
so much suspense for that it's locked
all right is the key in mother I need to
find the fuse box
I know let's do it all right we got
nothing
there's nothing I need that okay oh I
see a key take it
the key now I have to leave
I remember drawing these no he knows
what a gun looks like oh yeah it's this
dude with one eye have you seen this man
John
what does that say
Oh dolphin
and the dress
here we go
oh is this where the Commissioner goes
and I've taken the spoil supplies off
and spits it out 14 months at best if we
carry on as we are eight months for that
I've gone over it with dr. Hart on bare
minimum we might make 14 and bare
minimum means I didn't like to press any
but scurvy rickets first band then we
all just withered away to skin and bone
maybe I should just left the hatch open
and go for a nice stroll in the fresh
air instead what do we do we tell people
everything's all right it's not all
right one whiff of this and you'll have
your throat slit over the last sin of
peaches and Bunker humor is that the way
you want to die sir
fighting over scraps we could just cut
your wrists now and the rest of us will
split your rations [ __ ] up man it's her
medicine till the next bullet in
level two baby or should we keep going
downstairs
I wonder if there's more radiation
let's turn this night
John this is Alex stations
this is under Swan
the warning came he's with you on his
way his wife's name is Sarah
the radiation breach
thirty-six
it's going to be fine okay so maybe fine
isn't the right word but we have enough
supplies to make it through I'm sure of
it
if we can just keep it together and be
sensible with their rations then we can
make it sure none of us are going to get
fat down here but I could use losing a
few pounds anyway
level five he hates level five
communication from bunker HQ site three
caution Wiltshire Prime Minister
delivered safely before blast hits four
thousand and thirteen government
ministers and civil servants including
Cabinet Office local and national
government agencies intelligence and
security advisors logged in shortage
noted in domestic support staff guess
they didn't make it all facilities
operating normally checks carried out in
infirmary
bakery laundry kitchens telephone
exchange storerooms office space living
accommodation maintenance areas and
workshops propagates that place trust me
is under this sardine tin Prime Minister
unsatisfied with living accommodation
Dwight Howe other civilian casualties
noted outside bunker group of fifty
attempted to preach rear exit blast door
aggressive action not required activity
ceased after blast poor bastards
get together John you got this
so yeah this games on PC and it's out
next week on the 20th on Steam
I think there's a few spots right here
finding all my toys
one of these maps
commissioner I feel like the
Commissioner is like the overseer
well let's say for example the hit on
reading there's one Megaton term that
would mean we have this radius only
halfway to Basel ystös code now maybe
that looked small but that's around a
hundred thousand of fatalities maybe
eighty thousand injuries from the blast
on the fireball that's just to start
with prevailing wind direction here is
northeast fallout scatter will be huge
it's likely to drift all the way out
past Cambridge part nor achieve and out
to see the total number of casualties
unimaginable and that's one bomb up
okay
so I'm in this range right 80 virtually
no short-term effect no short-term some
nausea
all right now it says a bee welcomes ZB
asks clarification purpose of meeting a
bee puts forward petition from 18
residents keen to institute post of
morale officer it has felt that CB is
not forthcoming enough in communicating
current status bunker to residents CB
makes point that any urgent changes
status will be communicated very clearly
to all residents when it becomes
relevant in his view no need for new
position a bee sites to safety incidents
and asks committee if they were aware
Paul but f h DM SC are unaware of said
incidents CB says neither incident is
calls for immediate concern no need to
raise panic in difficult atmosphere
calls on F aides to clarify incidents fh
agrees not of immediate concern a B
raise his point that lack of trust in
bunker hierarchy is causing morale
issues more clarity and openness needed
CB reiterates appointed hierarchy and
his belief that no need for additional
officer if any critical incident comes
to light all will be made aware request
centre meeting has urgent business to
attend to a B calls for vote on
appointment of morale officer CB says
vote will be ignored not a democracy
meeting ended whose a bee
there's no B if these are just
abbreviations of these people
and I get that
alright that's this room commissioners
room yeah well with the greatest respect
sir we've been up all night it's been
ten minutes since I had to cover Vera's
face but I is it radiation I don't know
yet the nearest proper lab is under 10
tons of radioactive rubble and I have to
make do with a microscope it's all right
George we'll run some tests mr. Bishop
is anyone else showing signs yes six
others quarantine them right away mum I
don't think I'm here what's the matter I
can't sleep it's all right you know if
you stay in your room you'll be safe a
bit a tick
I don't like it here yeah let's look
closely a veloute Locker there's a
jagged end here it's not empty
Oh security cameras we were looking
through these right we turned them on no
we cannot Oh
I love that noise
that's too
residue around bulkhead seals
fresh beer ends down
biess 7.1 0.42 do about it rubber
compound shouldn't be perishing yet
indicates corrosion from something
unless the Cowboys used cottage cheese
instead of v8 VX compound given how the
rest of this place is built
filter system purifier lines
runs around the wall worried that we
might have a leak in the water system
okay that's why I probably people are
dying
a lot of people are taking notes on how
radiation is like possibly getting in
and not doing anything about it
god save the queen
let's go Mike
attention the mains power is about to be
switched off for maintenance purposes
dude there's no one else in the bunker
you weirdo or is there
man what's that solution
no one likes this one I bet the
Commissioner went crazy
in this room
all right
alright this were the fuse boxes for
sure
Essex only open one drawer at a time
it's empty
yeah it's empty too
bottoms up
alright well it's pretty dark behind you
all right
and that's that those are the fuses
I need a new fuse always disabused
hopefully yeah don't the replacement
I think I got this even though the notes
I wrote count really it bad
turn it off
replace damaged fuse that was intense
ah Shh it which one was it
damn I did its best five which fuse all
right whatever
I'd say it's this one it looks a little
a little job I can switch the power back
on now oh maybe I've replaced the fuse I
think it was fighting someone else is
battling him I was who is talking to me
all right let's go back to mom
no that doesn't sound good
like I'm hearing things all right
please be okay please be okay
you mentioned oh no location level the
war
I need to find the missus
I don't have any BC suit
a new NBC Superboy here telephone okay
no I
yes back literally means back I was
trying to go down the hallway
is there anything over here
so the store just has
I'm hungry I am
wonder if it's time to go to
it's emergency it's good
the map lights up if there's a leak
well let's
I want to check on mom
right
it's got a to
he's not gonna like it
but we're going to
yeah
I need to go
one ooh the war room
oh it's probably where I made my dolls
Sherlock you can be right at the front
with the tanks
so I with it
what couldn't you tell me yesterday
it's no help for any of them I I don't
know it's not radiation poisoning
the waters clean the air is clean it's
not the food yet the symptoms I can't
shake the feeling that someone is up to
something
damn ik George you don't have time for
your fantasies you need to figure this
out with facts we don't know where this
thing comes from or how it will spread
in a cause we have no cure we just don't
have the resources to deal with there is
no help
there is no cavalry there's just us so
get yourself together and fix this you
understand me what's that Oh cooling
system like a kid
I'm sorry mr. Bishop I'm I'm just on
edge this place it's full of ghosts
dang
a lot of people dead
soldier rocky way
what we don't know for certain is the
contamination levels we can calculate
the likely fallout and its effects but
we don't have any good model for anthrax
spores spread or even how its affected
by radiation look we do know from
reports at a three in Oxford that
anthrax was used in wave three
we've just got no idea of the extent of
it it's not as if we can go up and test
anything we can't even count the body
it's locked it's not emergency
Oh Oh what the hell whoa all right
jump-scare I
well let's take that what was it
in the event of a nuclear radiation leak
the following items required a complete
protection checklist for components
protective clothing gloves boots hood
respiratory system equipment gas masks
and purifiers
radiation detection battery no I just
took that okay
I'm sure suit integrity
make sure all zips are fastened all
right
let's put it on last suit will
everywhere
pyro
all right well I guess that's the room
this door only opens in an emergency
tripod
yeah
I can't I got a feeling that some of
these people were murdered I don't know
I don't know if anyone else got that
sense maybe maybe they were just like
yeah no it's it's probably
okay I have to cut away because I have
to double-check I got a double check I
think I cannot show any more of this
I'm sorry I just need to double-check
okay we're good
sorry for that
Oh
it's getting good huh things are heating
up
our filtration unit check day 18th of
October 95 1611 checked by BJT my own
filtration unit running okayed cleaned
out and replace filters check back up
just to be sure
readings are a behind but Frank Sesno
needs to replace at the moment probably
just as well I'm concerned about our
stock level two filters for the main uni
we're chewing through them a lot faster
than spec says due to higher outdoor
read than expected
Francis you've ever word with Bishop
about stocks sorting out the backup
longer-term
PJ PJ you're fired
everything looks normal
back to my peaches I love yours up
collect them all
the engineer
accident reports date 12th of August
92197 filed by run schedule test a
backup filtration unit rat that was way
too high on output over 500 bream red
lights across the board thought it was a
dust filter tried a new one
say sacrificed a geiger stuck it on a
rod and run it round inside the casing
we've got contaminated dust clogging the
lower decks dust god knows how it got in
might be a hairline
well maybe the filters couldn't cope
with the levels being so much higher
than we expected this is really really
bad
without thinking as a park cleaning
greasy and ding contaminating the whole
thing is useless we have no backup air
filtration system I can't see em can do
it it does have a clean space to do this
they ship just shrugs pretty much keep
it quiet Frank the only worried people
what else isn't he telling us
they're more drawers all right
let's back out I have to open it
you've got now
replace the filter immediately I feel
like I'm going to need a backup filter
probably even fine with this looking
good
was in there right
all right that's up
I need to turn off that steam
ah
I don't like this
latter business
I guess I'm your time we'll move it
first
can I keep going which is better open
this up
I know I know that noise means asbestos
yeah but see the holes standing still
next aspectus I need to get rid of this
damaged but oh that's why this is here I
thought I got through this sucker away
very good seal here's your radiation I
think I could use these to fix the unit
looks good
just one I need to turn the pressure
valve back on Oh
yeah I see it's a dude you're on ball
boys Oh
sorry sorry so that's it that's as far
as I'm allowed to go
yeah that's I'm not that into FMV games
but that's pretty entertaining I like to
see where that goes I'd like to see who
this suppose that killer is so yeah that
is the bunker available on Steam and it
comes out next week on the 20th as you
can check it out on Steam if you're
interested go for it but that is it for
today and the stream thanks for watching
and take care have a great weekend see
you guys around